the most beautiful place city was Prague
you know in the Czech Republic just the
people were really really interesting
and the city was was so filled with
history and I really enjoyed Prague one
of the most beautiful places I've ever
been in my life while filming we weren't
filming but I was was I had a day off
and I was riding a scooter around was on
an island called Patmos it's a holy
island and the Greek islands where Saint
John the Divine was supposed to have
written the book of apocalypse and I
went off I got off the beaten path and
it was driving this little moped down a
dirt road and I found a cove where there
was a farm that was an ancient farm that
was could have easily been a thousand
year old farm a little stone house with
these little Greek people with fingers
that were fat as potatoes and there was
fig trees and sheeps sheep and donkeys
and it was a completely self-sustaining
world right there that I imagine that
some of those people maybe never left
that spot that they had spent their
lives working the soil and taking care
of their animals and picking fruit from
the trees and in that particular moment
when I arrived there there was this Cove
and there was little ships where they
could go out little boats you know could
go out in the sea and catch fish so you
had the soil that was fertile the fig
trees the little people lemon trees and
then the Sun was just there setting in
the West with the water and it was all
the elements the sky the earth the Sun
and I SAT there on the scooter looking
at this place and I wept i mean i
literally just would not any desire to
just started crying about how beautiful
this this this corner of the world was
that how simple life can be and how
beautiful life can be and astonished
myself i was astonished at how
complicated we make our lives
you